you had a look of surprise on your face
even when this woman said well you know
norm was supposed to be my guide through
saturday night oh my god did anyone
inform you that you were her guy no no
no no no there was no such mentoring
program on saturday that live was it no
she came in directly after me so i
wouldn't be her
mentor yeah i'm not gonna guide any lady
through comedy that would take me uh
first of all i'd have to figure out how
a lady could do comedy
and of course it was very inspiring to
see
president clinton up here on crutches
making a speech i mean i thought that
was just amazing you know
i mean it's been difficult for the
president you know he can't jog now and
he needs help getting around and he's
still you know he still
occasionally suffers great pain you know
on the upside you got your medical
marijuana so that's uh
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're gonna get better
[Applause]
you've it's that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life i've
read six six what kind of a woman would
be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
no but greg corallo i'm just joking him
he has the grace of a swan the wisdom of
an owl and the eye of an eagle ladies
and gentlemen this man is for the birds
[Applause]
and there's charles woodson how about
that and what a season he had
great manny
he became the first defensive player to
win the heisman trophy and
congratulations charles that is
something that no one can ever take away
from you unless you kill your wife in a
waiter in which case
all bets are off
this is a word of advice
thanks i'm norm mcdonald and now the
fake news well it is finally official
murder is legal in the state of
california
[Applause]
testimony during the final week provided
some spell-binding moments
in a brilliant move during closing
arguments
simpson attorney johnny cochran put on
the knit cap prosecutors say o.j war the
night he committed the murders although
o.j may have hurt his case when he
suddenly blurted out hey hey easy with
that that's my lucky stabbing hat
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i bet the board is spelled b-o-r-e-d
who are safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55 percent of
adults feel that women are most
responsible for minor fender benders
while 78 blame men for most fatal
crashes please note that the percentages
in these pie graphs do not add up to 100
percent because the math was done by a
woman
for those of you hissing at that joke it
should be noted that that joke was
written by a woman so
now you don't know what the hell to do
it
[Applause]
no i'm just kidding we don't hire women
and finally weekend update would like to
congratulate madonna who gave birth to a
beautiful baby girl last monday the baby
weighed in at six pounds nine ounces
making it the fourth largest object ever
to pass through madonna's birth canal
what's that
oh yeah i know oh you're absolutely
right that is my name you know when the
people when the people here asked me to
do the show you know i gotta say i felt
kind of weird you know i i don't know if
you remember this but i used to actually
be on this show
you know
i used to do the weekend update news
routine you remember that and uh
yeah
that's where i did the make believe news
jokes you know that was me
right
so then a year and a half ago right i
had a sort of a disagreement with the
management at uh
at the nbc uh i wanted to keep my job
right
and they felt the exact opposite
so
so you see they like they fired me
because they said that i wasn't funny
you know now now with most jobs i could
have had a hell of a lawsuit on my hands
for that but
but see this is a comedy show
so they got me you know you know
you know what
but now this is a weird part right it's
only a year and a half later and now
they asked me to host the show
so i wondered i go hey wait a second
here hey
how did i go
in a year and a half
from being not funny enough
to be even allowed in the building
to being so funny that i'm now hosting
the show
how did i suddenly get so
damn funny
it was inexplicable to me because a year
and a half let's face is not enough time
for a dude to learn how to be fun
then it occurred to me
i haven't gotten funnier
the show
has gotten really bad
[Applause]
so yeah i'm funny compared to you know
well you'll see later but
okay so let's recap
the bad news is
i'm still not funny
the good news is the show blows
bob sagan that's why we're all here bob
bob you have a lot of well-wishers here
tonight and a lot of them would like to
throw you down one
a well
they want to murder you in a well
it seems a little harsh but
apparently they want to murder you in a
well
it says here on this card
[Applause]
no but bob has a beautiful face like a
flower yeah a cauliflower
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no offense but
your face
looks
like a cauliflower
[Applause]
as you can see he has wavy hair
it's waving goodbye on account he's
going bald
[Applause]
no i think that uh
that bob should join the ku klux klan
and that's not because he's racist
he's not racist
it's just that he'd look a lot better
with a hood over his head
on account of his
face i heard you have hair on your chest
bob and uh well let me tell you
something
that isn't your only resemblance to rin
tin tin
[Laughter]
your [ __ ] dog face
[Applause]
how can you not get that
[Applause]
no there are times when bob has
something on his mind when he wears a
hat
with no thoughts at all
just a hat
and bob is not very worldly
he thinks the english channel is a
british tv station and not a body of
water separating england and france
and bob isn't the biggest sports fan i
don't think i'm telling any uh tails out
of school i took him to a
i took him to a ball game
and he came toting a double-barreled
shotgun you remember that
i said what the h is that for
bob said i heard the lions were playing
the tigers you remember that yeah
[Applause]
now he's a good guy he's a good guy he's
never bought christmas seals he told me
he wouldn't know what to feed them
yeah and is that how big your [ __ ] is no
i was like i'm just [ __ ] going
through the [ __ ]
[ __ ] to make people think it's that big
it's not okay it's not that bad so all
right so i'm going through the process
and i want to do so back i'm in the back
of the dressing room and then boom
it's blood oh no what the hell yeah yeah
i can't have the [ __ ] blood oh no and
i put it back in my pants oh my god oh
my god i'm dead i got a disease i got a
[ __ ] disease
oh [ __ ]
i didn't have sex who's the last girl i
had sex with back then i think i was on
drugs last time i had sex so who would
that girl i don't even know her name
[ __ ] dracula or something wasn't a
dracula it could have been you i don't
know it was just any thousands of nights
it was just it was just blood ejaculated
blood and i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna die of
course you're gonna die
what happened i don't know it didn't
happen again you never you didn't see it
if you seek a physician no it was scared
for them to tell me what it was you just
oh i said yeah so you're ignoring me
exactly i always have a second catch you
[ __ ] dripping i'll be dripping like a
good human in july and i'm scared to go
because i'm thinking i got eight
he made a terrible mistake he took the
age test he crammed the night before
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm like i have to ask you a question
say it
i can't say it let it make him sick
make adam he could say it might god damn
people often see me you know the real
heroes are they're real heroes
[Music]
it's counterintuitive that
it doesn't seem like a heroic job but
yes
[Laughter]
first of all if you're a teacher you
have the same button vacations as a
child
like four months a year
my vacation
i get almost no time out there we're 48
weeks a year
four weeks a year i get up
what about you
[Music]
that's a easy one
it's always easy to ask the questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]